مشهدا اخر هذه المره من مجمع الشفاء الطبي
حيث يقف مراسلنا اسماعيل الغول اسماعيل
كذلك على مستوى ايى النازحين واستقبال
المزيد من المصابين وجثامين الشهداء على
مستوى مجمع الشفاء الطبي ما الذي تخبرنا
به
هناك صحيح تتوافد الاصابات تباعا وفي
الواقع القصف الاسرائيلي لم يتوقف رغم
انخفاض حده وتيرته في مختلف المناط
داخل مدينه غزه لكن الان القصف الاسرائيلي
وتوافد الاصابات الى هذا المكان وا هذذه
الاسعافات قبل لحظات نقلت اصابات الى هذا
المكان بشكل ملحوظ الاصابات تتزايد ساعه
بعد ساعه انخفاض وتيره القصف الحربي الذي
يكون من طائرات الاف 16 والاف 35 هو
انخفاض ملحوظ لكن تستمر القصف القصف
المدفعي وما يسمى قذائف
الهازرد المباشر للمواطنين تركزت
استهدافات الاحتلال على التجمعات مثلا
تجمعات تعبئه المياه
تجمعات طلب الاحتياجات هذه مما تسبب الى
ارتكاب مجازر كبيره داخل مدينه غزه لكن
الاصابات لم تتوقف ولا للحظه من القدوم
رغم قله الامكانات الطبيه وقله المعدات
الطبيه وقله الادويه والمستلزمات داخل
مجمع الشفا الطبيه لكن وفق مصادر طبيه
تحدثت لنا ان هناك الامم
المتحده ستعمل على احضار بعض الاطباء وفي
غالبهم عددهم اربع اطباء في تخصصات مختلفه
للاشراف على اجراء عمليات بعد توقف
العمليات لايام داخل مجمع الشفاء الطبي
بالاضافه الى ذلك عملت الامم المتحده على
توفير بعض ومنظمه الصحه العالميه بالاضافه
الى كل ه المنظمات هذهه المنظمات العامله
داخل مدينه غزه عادت للعمل بشكل ملحوظ في
شمال قطاع غزه لكن بالتحديد داخل مدينه
غزه شمال القطاع لا يتواجد به اي مشفى
داخل مجمع الشفاء الطبي وفروا بعض الوقود
وهم الان يعملون على احضار بعض الاطباء
ويعملون الى تجهيز كشوفات لاجلاء بعض
المرضى الكثير من الاحداثيات لم تظهر بعد
وهي كثيره في داخل مجمع الشفاء الطبي حتى
هذه اللحظه يعني ننتظر تنتظر وزاره الصحه
الايفاء بالوعود وخاصه باحضار الاطباء
لاحظنا في الايام الاخيره توافد الوفود
بشكل يومي تقريبا وهذا دليل واضح على
موافقه قوات الاحتلال يبدو على اعاده
تشغيل مجمع الطبي رغم الدمار الكبير في
هذا المجمع تحاول المنظمه احياء هذا
المجمع وتحاول الطواقم الطبيه العمل على
اعاده تشغيل العمليات داخل المجمع رغم
الدمار الكبير داخل اقسام العمليات لكن
هناك عدد من المعيقات وابرز هذه المعيقات
هو عدد النازحين الكبير داخل مجمع الشفاء
الطبي الذي يصعب اجلائهم من داخل اقسام
العمليات لكن الطواقم الطبيه تعمل بكل جهد
لاعاده تشغيل هذه الاقسام طبعا وانت تتحدث
اسماعيل الحركه دؤوب هنا في ساحه مدخل
الطوارئ لمجمع الشفاء الطبي طبعا تزامنا
مع القصف المكثف المستمر على احياء وسط
غزه يضطر هذا المستشفى للتعامل مع هذه
الحالات على الرغم من ان معظم اقسامه
مازالت لم يعد تشغيلها مره اخرى بالتالي
تحول هذا المستشفى الى مر مز ايواء
والى مستشفى ايضا او مركز طبي
يستقبل المصابين على صعيد ايواء النازحين
وتوفير الغذاء والماء والمستلزمات الطبيه
ما الذي استجد
اسماعيل صحيح تزداد الحركه وقد نرى في هذه
الصوره قدوم وفد يو ان دي بي او الامم
المتحده ومنظمات الصحه العالميه التابع
ايضا هذه السياره تابعه لليو ان في هذه
اللحظات التي تدخل بها الوفود الى مدينه
غزه تخف وتيره القصف بشكل ملحوظ وهذا يزيد
من حركه السكان وحركه النازحين لطلب
احتياجاتهم والبحث عن احتياجاتهم بشكل
ملحوظ الان هذا هذه الوفود هي حتى هذه
اللحظه لم ت لم تحضر ولم تدخل سوى المعدات
الطبيه الى مدينه غزه لم تدخل الد لم تدخل
عفوا الطعام لم تدخل المياه لم تدخل
الاحتياجات الاساسيه في داخل المدينه وهذا
الامر هو ما يسبب اعاقه كبيره امام حركه
السكان وامام حياتهم اليوميه وبالكاد يجد
السكان شربه ماء سليمه وبسبب الماء
الملوثه انتشرت الامراض الكارثيه ووصلت
الى الكثير من السكان الاعياء الشديد
مصاحب لهذا البرد بسبب عدم صحيه المياه
بالاضافه الى فقدان الكثير من الاغذيه
الاساسيه مثل الدقيق والارز وكثير من
الاغذيه التي يعتاش عليها هؤلاء المواطنون
اسماعيل الغول من مجمع الشفاء الطبي في
مدينه غزه شكرا جزيلا لك